au début de l'année 2010 est alors que
la campagne pour la présidentielle bat
son plein un article du canard enchaîné
fait l'effet d'une bombe le 25 janvier
2017 l'hebdomadaire affichant une ce
titre les 600000 euros gagnés par
pénélope qui empoisonnent fillon le
journal fait état d'une rémunération
perçue par l'épousé de l'ancien premier
ministre
le canard avance notamment les sommes
obtenues entre 1998 et 2002 et ensuite
jusqu'en 2006 pénélope fillon aurait
donc été rémunéré au titre d'attaché
parlementaire de son mari puis de son
suppléant pendant toutes ces années
le jour même de ses révélation par le
canard enchaîné le parquet national
financé ouvre une enquête préliminaire
pour détournement de fonds publics abus
de biens sociaux et recel de ces délits
françois fillon qui avait fait de sa
probité un argument de campagne lors de
la primaire de la droite affirme qu'il
va se battre pour défendre son honneur
le 6 février lors d'un meeting à paris
est le candidat de la droite prend la
parole comment peut-on imaginer un seul
instant que mon épouse qui a collaboré
avec moi depuis près de 30 ans
principalement dans le département de la
sarthe et dans ma circonscription puisse
l'avoir fait à l'insu de son plein gré
mais au fil des jours les révélations se
succèdent une vieille interview de
pénélope fillon daté de 2007 refait
surface
entretien au cours duquel elle affirme
n'avoir jamais était assistante de son
mari
d'autres détails de la sphère continue
de sortir et la pression médiatique et
populaire se fait de plus en plus fait
trente six ans de vie politique
36 ans sans jamais aucun problème
d'ordre judiciaire
je suis aujourd'hui la cible d'une
attaque impitoyable partial 7 jours sur
7 24 heures sur 24
et tout ceci pour des faits anciens
connus légaux est ce que c'est juste
est-ce que c'est équitable le 24 février
2010 est le pnf annonce l'ouverture
d'une information judiciaire
malgré cela françois fillon assure qu'il
restera candidats sa diatribe qui
imagine le général de gaulle mise en
examen prononcée en août 2016 est
désormais aussi célèbre qu'encombrant
voir un candidat de plus en plus
fragilisé conséquence dans les sondages
celui qui fut un temps le favori des
intentions de vote pour la
présidentielle dégringole en l'espace de
deux mois et se fait dépasser
respectivement par marine le pen et
emmanuel macron qui seront finalement
second tour petit à petit certains de
ses soutiens le lâche thierry solère
bruno le maire ou encore gilles boyer
kitona vie
[Applaudissements]
seul
la fin de la campagne présidentielle
sera ponctuée de nouvelles révélations
et de nouvelles affaires il est
notamment question de costumes de luxe
offert à françois fillon encore du poste
de pénélope fillon au sein de la revue
des deux mondes le soir du premier tour
de la présidentielle françois fillon
recueille un peu plus de 20% des
suffrages et pointe à la troisième place
un échec qui signe son départ de la vie
politique
discret depuis l'élection présidentielle
françois fillon a rompu son silence
médiatique en janvier 2020 s'il écarte
tout retour en politique l'ancien
candidat de la droite explique vouloir
défendre son honneur et celui de sa
famille françois fillon qui estime je
cite à la minute où cette affaire a été
engagée par le parquet national
financiers il était décidé de m'empêcher
de gagner l'élection présidentielle
au-delà de l'aspect judiciaire c'est
donc une affaire éminemment politique
qui va être jugé
après deux ans d'enquêté ce procès
retentissant devrait durer jusqu'au 11
mars